our question of the day comes from
Benjamin in Virginia afternoon David
just got engaged whoo we're beginning to
plan our wedding whoo-hoo
should I hit pause on my dad snowball
yes to pay cash for the wedding yes also
would it be okay to set up a joint
checking account when I'm with my fiance
specifically for wedding saving and
expenditures only yes this would allow
us to save together and hold each other
accountable on wedding expenditures
while also keeping our personal finances
separate yes we paid for our daughter's
weddings and that's exactly how we did
it we sat down with the bride and groom
to be they put together a wedding budget
which you need to do always when you're
doing a wedding because they get out of
control and with the wedding budget we
agreed to that number we put that number
in a checking account that was a joint
checking account between the future
bride and groom it was the wedding
account and there was not going to be
any more money put into that account
that was the budget that's what we
agreed on all four of us agreed we wrote
the check and then at that point the
father of the bride is done I don't have
to get into the cheaper chicken
discussion I don't have to get into the
chairs discussion I don't have to get
into these things you simply stay on
that budget and by the way a wedding and
I know it's a romantic and wonderful
time and we like throwing a party where
Ramses we like to dance and we like to
have a big time and celebrate the you
know this wonderful occasion we had big
it's a big party for us we like it and
we had three great big weddings all
three of our kids we just love them and
of course we weren't in charge of the
last one with my son getting married but
hey we got in the middle of it we're
there and we like having the party so
we're not against the romance of it but
it's a project it's an event you're an
event planner and you need to be an
event planner and you need to stay on
budget and you need to understand what
the budget elements are and what you've
got allocated for the photographer what
you've got allocated for the dress what
you've got allocated for the preacher
what you've got allocated for the venue
and the big dog on
list particularly if you're gonna have
more than six or eight people come is
going to be your reception and that's
the more expensive item on the list and
you write that out and you look at your
food cost and you look at the venue cost
and the deejay or the band or the who
whatever Billy Bob with his iPod I don't
know what it is but somebody's doing
something and we got to write all this
out and we have to have a game plan and
then if you have a thousand dollars
budgeted for the dress you don't spend
$8,000 that's not what you do and
whatever the number is you got to have
something you manage to the number and
you manage the date and it's a project
it's project management and this is how
we're doing it